Dominique Loiseau vous nous le disiez en
démarrant cette émission votre passion
c'est le jardin est particulièrement les
roses aujourd'hui vous êtes gâté ah oui
c'est merveilleux ça permet de vous
évader un petit peu du stress de tout ce
monde qui va vite je ne sais pas si ça
me permet de m'évader parce que je suis
quand même plus dans le jardin que dans
le reste donc c'est même pas une évasion
c'est une permanence de votre voisin pas
qu'on va avec vous aussi parce que lui
c'est son métier qu'il est osiriste
Christophe ça fait cette génération donc
vous connaissez les roses entre
guillemets par cœur on a l'habitude de
dire qu'en principe ce sont les filles
qui naissent dans les roses et les
garçons dans les choux alors vous c'est
tout l'inverse exactement ça c'est
plutôt passé comme ça je suis né dans
les roses au milieu des rosiers avec mes
parents qui étaient rosiristes vous vous
cassez le mythe c'est une longue
histoire familiale c'est une très longue
histoire familiale ça serait un peu trop
long de remonter tout ce temps mais
voilà donc c'était inscrit dans nos
gènes Dominique vous avez un
pépinieriste et rosieriste depuis cette
génération chez à berre-le-châtel
j'imagine que vous avez plein de
questions à lui poser parce que vous
vous qui avez des roses entre autres à
ce lieu quelle est la première
interrogation qui vous vient tout de
suite la face à un spécialiste comme ça
un expert
ou je n'ai pas de j'ai pas de question à
lui poser en particulier des questions
c'est plutôt des compliments que j'ai
envie de lui faire et puis c'est les
roses que j'ai envie de de sentir de
regarder
j'aurais trop de questions à lui poser
en fait alors moi j'ai l'avantage
d'avoir vu quelques-unes de rose il y a
450 variétés on les a pas toutes sur ce
plateau mais au moins on voit en même
temps qu'on parle quelques photos aussi
de rose
je précise qu'il y a actuellement en ce
joli mois de septembre la possibilité
pour celles et ceux qui sont amoureux de
rose comme vous l'êtes Dominique de se
rendre chez vous et d'aller visiter et
de se rendre compte que c'est magnifique
mais surtout il y en a beaucoup voilà
donc en septembre on profite de la
remontée des des rosiers pour pouvoir
ouvrir en fait l'idée c'est de m'avoir
un catalogue assez ouvert parce que
parfois on choisit les roses sur le
papier c'est pas toujours évident et là
c'est vraiment une occasion unique en
tout cas dans la région de d'aller se
promener au milieu des rosiers des roses
un peu plus de 30000 euros en fleurs en
ce moment et la visite est ouverte et
grande ouverte vous êtes déjà allé
Dominique
[Musique]
merci la clé de votre succès à vous
Christophe et de votre particularité
finalement ce sont les rosiers adaptés
pour notre terroir qui est
particulièrement calcaire parce que
c'est ça le secret d'un bon jardinier
c'est d'avoir les roses qui vont bien
dans le bon jardin en fait l'idée
c'était pour moi de d'avoir à produire
un rosier qui soit parfaitement adapté à
son terroir initialement le rosier n'est
pas très adapté au sol calcaire et donc
on a trouvé par une technique qui
s'appelle la technique du greffage le
moyen de de d'adapter en fait les
rosiers à la nature du sol donc au sol
calcaire de la région et également au
froid puisque le la région avec le
climat continental on a ces grandes
variations de température entre les
froids l'hiver et puis les grandes
chaleurs l'été et le rosier tel qu'on le
produit permet justement cette
adaptation Dominique vous connaissez la
technique du graissage du greffage
c'est encore différent
mais en ce qui concerne la rose c'est
quand même la rose qui supporte une
c'est la fleur qui supporte tout quand
il fait sec quand il fait chaud quand il
gèle enfin il y a pas tellement d'autres
plantes enfin fleuries qui puissent
supporter tout ça et tous les hivers
elle
disparaissent un peu puis au printemps
elle revienne je veux dire par exemple
du une résistance quand même hors du
commun vous avez devant vous une rose
qui porte votre nom c'est la rose
Dominique l'oiseau c'est la rose blanche
oui on me l'a attribué en 2003 l'année
où Bernard est décédé et ça a été pour
moi
une énergie qui m'a bien permis de tenir
de ça m'a fait énormément de bien
vraiment cette rose comment vous la
qualifiez pour celles et ceux qui
connaissent pas
suffisant effectivement c'est un rosier
buisson vous voyez qui fait des buissons
et c'est une rose
comme les roses sauvages voyez la
manière dont elle est faite à
l'intérieur où est la caméra
voilà et puis elle est très résistante
elle remonte tout le temps il pleut
depuis 3 jours après et la remonté elle
exactement elle est très résistante
comme moi très bien
dites-moi Christophe puisqu'on parle de
Rosa à son nom
votre papa qui nous regarde peut-être de
tout en haut va être particulièrement
fier de la famille parce que très
bientôt vous allez inaugurer la rose de
votre papa aussi c'est ça voilà un
hommage il sera rendu par rapport à
justement à cette fibre qu'il assume
transmettre ça mon papa je l'ai pas
connu beaucoup mais néanmoins voilà il y
a l'idée de lui de lui assurer cet
hommage avec l'arrivée d'un nouveau
rosier qui s'appelle qui s'appelle Louis
Dima puisque c'était c'était son nom et
il est présenté ici là donc c'est une
nouveauté qui sera baptisée la semaine
prochaine en présence de de Paul
Lefebvre qui est un quelqu'un
d'éminement connu dans le monde de la
choses puisqu'il est il était président
de la section rose de la Société
d'horticulture nationale et donc il sera
son parrain et il viendra le 24 à la
pépinière le 24 septembre prochain
baptisé rosier je vais venir avec
juste en tout cas des outils de jardin
vous-même Dominique quel est l'outil que
vous utilisez le plus dans votre jardin
le sécateur
oui le sécateur c'est l'outil de base du
jardinier alors là on a pris un couteau
pour faire quoi dites moi alors j'ai
juste amené de quoi expliquer comment on
greffe puisque c'est quand même un peu
la technique justement particulière je
sais pas si je le montre maintenant
c'est d'expliquer qu'à partir d'un tout
petit bourgeon qui se trouve placé ici
et bien en fait c'est ce petit bourgeon
qu'on va prélever par la méthode du
greffage comme ça en faisant un
prélèvement avec un écusson noir ça sera
un petit clin d'œil au coutelier donc en
faisant ce prélèvement de cette façon
et on a le positionner ce petit écusson
sur un porte-greffe c'est comme ça qu'on
réussit à produire de nouveaux rosiers
et donc c'est de par cette méthode au
mois d'août qu'on réalise notre
opération et c'est la condition
nécessaire pour ensuite propager les
variétés qu'on souhaite multiplier avec
ce petit ce petit cette petite
bandelette qui est en fait ce qu'on
appelle du vitagreph qui permet de
protéger la greffe une fois qu'elle est
faite c'est de vitagre c'est du
caoutchouc avec une épingle en cuivre et
en fait c'est un produit qui est
totalement dégradable qui se dégrade
tout seul une fois que la greffe est
faite et bien on va positionner cela sur
le greffon et ça permet de d'assurer la
bonne reprise de la greffe donc ce vitre
à greffe qui se détruit tout seul
pas du tout non je ne me lance pas dans
tellement d'opérations complexe non
c'est pas vous qui jardinez
c'est quand même il faut savoir le faire
et puis on trouve
tellement belle rose chez les
rosieristes que pourquoi s'embêter à la
maison en greffée en revanche je sais
que mon rosier par exemple a été greffé
sur une base qui est très résistante au
froid voyez c'est la base qui donne
après la qualité de la fleur c'est
exactement ça c'est la condition le
porte-greffe le système racinaire en
fait c'est la condition de faire vivre
les rosiers dans de bonnes conditions
ici dans nos régions mais c'est
absolument nécessaire quand vous achetez
un rosier aujourd'hui il est important
de d'interroger celui qui vous le vend
en lui demandant sur quel porte-greffe
il a été installé on est en Bourgogne
Franche-Comté est-ce que la Bourgogne a
le même terrain que la Franche-Comté
alors évidemment on peut avoir des
variations par exemple dans le Morvan on
peut avoir des terrains un peu plus
acides mais les sols calcaire ça
représente environ 40% de des sols des
sols qui sont présents en France donc ça
veut dire que d'une zone à l'autre on
peut aussi avoir besoin de par exemple
dans la région PACA dans la région des
Charentes dans le Centre France vers la
bosse la région parisienne on retrouve
ses sols calcaires et on a besoin
d'avoir ces plantes adaptées à ces
soldes chez vous on a un hectare de
rosiers on a 450 variétés 30 000 rosiers
on a toutes sortes de rosiers et c'est
en fleur en ce moment et donc voilà
venez en prendre plein les yeux c'est le
moment c'est étonnant Dominique autant
de roses chez nous et le paradis ça
joli paradis fleuri des rosiers
botaniques des rosiers à grande fleurs
des grimpants découvre sol il y a
beaucoup de variétés en pot pour la
terrasse parce que c'est vrai qu'il y en
a qui sont très gentil mais moi j'ai pas
de jardin alors les rosiers peuvent
aussi se se plaire en pot il y a
quelques exemples ici c'est ces petits
rosiers là par exemple ça c'est une
vérité qui s'appelle rêve de Paris qui
est tout à fait destiné à vivre en pot
sur une terrasse sur un balcon à
condition qu'elle soit évidemment bien
bien entretenu et bien soigné mais voilà
c'est le genre de rosier qui peuvent
tout à fait prédisposés à une culture en
pot ils peuvent vivre plusieurs années
en pot par rapport à ces rosiers là qui
sont plutôt des grands rosiers qui vont
se développer plutôt dans des grands
massifs dans dans le jardin par exemple
les rosiers ont besoin de soleil d'une
façon générale il faut quand même du
soleil et du soleil
par jour quoi
c'est important il faut pas qu'ils
soient en endroit on me rasé